a very warm welcome to everyone I'm sure
she SH product manager for Google cloud
storage or GCS and I have with me
Chester tech lead for GCS as well and in
this session we are going to learn about
some important security capabilities and
best practices to keep your data safe
and secure at scale on GCS so agenda
first we are going to look at GCS as a
product and its various capabilities
then we are going to go through some
highly differentiated security
fundamentals that GCS has to offer and
then Chester is going to take you
through some highlighted security
features and some security best
practices to secure your data at scale
and then we are going to end with a demo
which you put together these various
security capabilities and best practices
so introduction what is DCS and why it
is awesome so GCS or Google Cloud
Storage is GC p's object or blob storage
product it's a very simple product to
use from the customer perspective
because of various reasons but two
fundamental reasons one is that GCS
offers a consistent API across all
different storage classes and the second
is DCS offers uniform online latency
characteristics across all different
storage classes so whether you are
interacting with the hottest storage
class or the coldest storage class your
code doesn't need to change because they
pay is the same and your handling in the
code doesn't need to change because
across all is this difference towards
classes you have the same online latency
characteristics this is highly reliable
GCS offers various geo redundancy
options ranging from a region to a
country to a continent based on what
your use cases and GCS is highly
cost-effective
you can leverage object lifecycle
management to spread your cost across
all different storage classes of GCS now
last but not the least and the focus of
this session GCS is highly secure and is
inbuilt with a bunch of fundamental
security capabilities that you got that
you get straightaway of the box when you
use GCS so in terms of key features I
have already mentioned about the unified
experience through the API is and the
latency characteristics so
yes of a strongly consistent listing
worldwide and what we see is other than
GCSE and other public cloud storages are
being used customers usually use a key
value database to drag this consistency
because they do not get it
of the box with other public cloud
storage offerings but that is an
additional unit of cost and management
which you do not have to do with GCS I
have already mentioned your redundancy
the other great aspect of using GCS is
you do not need to worry about scale at
all we have single customers in GCS who
scaled to exabytes of bigger now in
terms of the use cases we see standard
storage class being used in two
different classes of use cases we see
dual regional and regional standard
locations location types being used for
highly compute intensive use cases for
example for high performance computing
or for analytics or for machine learning
what we also see is customers leverage
GCS as multi-regional storage locations
CDN like characteristics because of its
intelligent edge caching and routing
capabilities for content distribution
use cases and Nearline is great if what
you are looking to do is backup colon is
great if what you are looking to do is
archive and the archive storage class
itself is great if what you are trying
to do is to do long term archival for
regulatory or compliance purposes so
what we see is archive storage class is
a great tape replacement but once you
have your data in archive storage class
your data is still live is in a serving
tier and that brings me to the fact that
once you have your data in GCS you have
this great advantage that the entire
data platform that is Google is now open
to you so once you have your data in GCS
whatever it is that you want to do with
your data whether you want to run AI or
machine learning or you want to do
analytics whatever it is that you want
to do you can do once you have landed
your data in GCS now security is not an
afterthought for us
GCSE we have built GCSE with security as
a fundamental primitive and this starts
with Google's private network so Google
possibly has the world's largest private
network so we have thousands of edge
node locations we have hundreds of pop
node locations so wherever you are
producing your data for consumer
consuming your data from you are never
too far away from one of Google's edge
or pop locations and how that helps you
a lot is say if you are in a particular
location and you are writing your data
to a Google Cloud Storage bucket in a
different region with GCS your data
packets enter Google's closest pop and
then it traverses Google's private
network all the way up to the region now
if you compare it with another public
cloud vendor what will happen is your
data packets should pass through the
public internet up to the region where
your data is stored so you have much
higher exposure that way when you use
GCS your data packets are flowing
through Google's private network for
most of its lifetime so your exposure to
public internet is as low as possible
encryption is another very important
aspect of security and with GCS all your
data is always encrypted so whether it
is your data in flight or whether it is
your data at rest all of your data in
Jesus is always encrypted and we offer
you entire range in terms of choice for
managing your encryption keys so whether
you want to use customer-supplier
encryption keys or you want to use
customer management efficient keys or
hardware security module or you just
want to use Google's default automatic
encryption you have all your choices
when you use GCS and then the last part
that I would emphasize on GCS is
fundamental security fundamentals is
even if you use the most sophisticated
security capability with GCS for example
if you use KMS keys or if you want to
put your GCS buckets behind a vp c
security firewall you do not have to pay
any penalty in terms of your performance
or your sls
we have built all the security
capabilities with GCS from from ground
up so that your experience of using them
is the same as if you are using GCS even
without these features in terms of the
performance and the SLS there is
absolutely no penalty that you need to
pay with that I'm going to hand it over
to Chester who's going to take you
through some security features and some
best practices and then we are going to
end with the demo take it over Chester
thanks you the features I'll be going
over today are uniform buckle access
iron conditions service account each mat
keys and d4 signatures uniform pocket
level access when GA last year and this
is a bucket level setting that lets you
simplify access control across all
objects within a bucket when enabled
permissions are managed using the
buckets ion policy disabling the use of
individual object Ackles since all
objects now share the same configuration
it's much easier to tell if any objects
are publicly exposed to the internet by
inspecting your bucket policy you can
quickly determine who can or cannot
access your data uniform buffer level
access also helps you leverage a
security feature called domain
restricted sharing which enforces that
all members of an ion policy must be
within a specified domain
I am conditions brings HP based access
control of GCS by extending AIIMS policy
language with conditional bindings this
recently GA feature allows you to grant
access based on a resource name or a
request timestamp a simple example that
combines both attributes is if you tried
to grant future access to all objects
whose name started with 2020 slash I've
also included a cell expression at the
bottom of the slide that you could use
to implement such a condition some of
you may already be familiar with user
account each map keys but I'd like to
introduce you to service account each my
keys which are now GA service account
hmm keys are similar to user account in
that they're also a type of credential
that can be used to create signatures
which you can include in your requests
to GCS
these signatures show that the request
is authorized by the entity that owns
the HVAC key delegating that entity's
access to the request you managed
service account each man keys by calling
our API is to generate HTML credential
which consists of an access key and a
secret so if you're already using user
account each map there's no need to
change your code you can simply update
the access key and secret that your code
is using with service account HVAC
you'll also get better key lifecycle
management from the cloud console UI you
can quickly create rotate disable and
delete branch becky's and lastly surface
account each map is interoperable with
other public clouds which will enable
your app for multi cloud for customers
who work with multiple public clouds GCS
is also gone ga with RV for signature
support before enables you to access
multiple object stores with the same
client code and it's available for both
RSA and service account page monkeys now
I'd like to show you how these features
can help you secure your data at scale
to start I'll go over fundamentals like
work policies and the differences
between pod a.m. and GCS apples also
explain how uniform bug level access
simplifies access control at scale and
then I'll conclude with some best
practices for using hmm keys with GCS
within GCP all resources conform to a
resource hierarchy GCS is no different
your buckets hold objects and they're
associated with projects and projects
can be nested inside folders and our
tied to organizations or policies are
settings that you configure at the org
folder or project level to enforce a
service specific behavior so remember
that all resources inherit from or
policy step higher in the hierarchy so
if you set an ork policy at the org
level it would cover all GCS buckets in
its tree and lastly our policies
themselves are not retroactive because
they take effect after they are enforced
so hypothetically if there was an org
policy that prevented buckets from being
created in a specific region enabling it
now wouldn't impact any buckets that
were created before that orc Posse was
enforced the two orc policies that we
recommend enabling with GCS are domain
restricted sharing and uniform bug level
access the first one prevents users from
adding members outside your organization
to ion policies controlling access to
your GCS resources so if you try to make
the contents of the bucket public to the
Internet by adding all users member to
the bucket policy this org policy when
enabled what
block that operation and I'll cover this
in the demo the second drug policy
enforces the use of uniform bucket level
access so after you enable this all
newly created buckets are acquiring to
manage to access uniformly through the
bucket policy and this is also covered
in the demo the easiest way to set an
orc policy is through the cloud console
UI for certain or policies like domain
restricted sharing you will need to know
your organization's domain ID as well
and if you don't have it totally fine
you can always use g-cloud to find it
I'd like to go over a brief history of
GCS access control in the beginning GCS
only supported apples and then cloud I
am came along in GCS integrated with I
am at the bucket level so today when you
configure access to GCS you should be
aware that there are actually two
systems at play here
there's cloud I am and in CCS apples
access can be granted from either system
but cloud ion behaves that pork policies
and that they also follow the resource
hierarchy so any object permissions when
granted at the bucket level they
automatically apply to all objects
underneath that bucket GC has apples on
the other hand they do not follow a
resource hierarchy they are used at the
object level and can only grant access
to individual objects in general we
recommend using cloud I am to authorize
access to GCS because it is integrated
with so many security and privacy
features like domain restricted sharing
in combat a lot since objects can have
unique Eckles it gets harder to tell who
has access to your data the longer your
bucket has been in production imagine
having to iterate across millions or
billions of objects in order to check to
see if a specific user is granted or
denied access Danny objects you can see
that this can quickly become a
maintenance burden and our
recommendation for managing lots of
object ackles at scale is to not manage
them at all by enabling uniform bubble
level access you are disabled in object
Ackles and using the bucket policy for
all access control every object is
treated the same and every object
benefits from all of Iams feature
integrations and added benefit to using
this feature is that GCS can now share
access to decisions for objects within
the same bucket caching is improved
which is great for high KPS use cases
and we understand that some of our
customers continue to use GCS apples
for different reasons whether it's
because of their multi-cloud
architecture or because echoes allow you
to share an object with an individual
user in general it is not a best
practice to put in end-users on your
object ackles so I'd like to recommend
some alternatives
first sign URLs send URLs allow you to
delegate time limited access to your GCS
resources your code generates a URL
which contains authentication info in
the query string that's tied to a
specific identity usually the service
account and that URL sent to an end-user
for tumblr second if you notice that
certain groups of objects happen to
share the same access pattern within
your bucket like they have the same
object Apple step then this might be a
sign that you should be using separate
buckets one for each use case and lastly
if your app makes use of shared prefixes
in object naming then you could also use
I'm conditions to shard access based on
those prefixes and finally I'd like to
explain some best practices when using
HTML keys on GCS first off we recommend
service account hmm / user account each
map surface accounts in general they
offer more reliability because they are
tied to the lifetime of the cloud
project whereas user accounts or not the
user account can easily be deleted
outside the context of GCP for example
when a collaborator leaves the
organization or when an employee leaves
the company if this happens
deactivating that uses your account
would also deactivate their HVAC keys
and this would result in access to not
errors for any code that was relying on
those keys so we definitely recommend
using surface account hmm keys in the
production service other things we
recommend we recommend rotating your
keys and only granting your service
accounts just enough permissions to
accomplish whatever task they're trying
to do and lastly if you're using v2
signatures we recommend setting
reasonable expiration times as well as
eventually migrating to V 4 V 4 enforces
a max time limit of one week whereas v2
has an element which can be risky all
right time for demo all right let's
begin the demo by enabling the org
policies that I mentioned in the best
practice
is section before so do this we'll go to
the orc policy editor and we will
configure tomato shifted sharing and
uniform bucket level access so let's
start with the first one and for a
domain restricted sharing you're going
to need your domain ID and if you don't
know that off the top of your head no
worries
you can use g-cloud to list the
organizations that you have access to
you can see here I have a test org and
this value on the right is going to be
my domain ID so I'm gonna throw it here
that here into the policy value select
save great now only members of this
domain ID are allowed on ion policies
anywhere in my project go back to this
or policy view select enforce and we
will customize it set the enforcement on
as well
so now that I've configured this or
policy if for uniform buckle-up access
any new bucket will have to use that
feature which will greatly simplify
access control across objects in buckets
from here let's go to storage browser
and see these or policies in action so
we create bucket let's call this bucket
GCS next on here
we'll use the defaults for data location
in storage class and we can see here
that the org policy I enabled earlier
enforces uniform for access control I'm
going to create the bucket now and let's
make sure domain restricted sharing is
also in effect as well so to do that
we'll go to permissions and we'll try to
add something that's outside the domain
if I were to add all users which would
grant access to everyone making the
bucket publicly exposed on the internet
that would violate the domain restricted
sharing or policy and so I am expecting
this to fail and we see that the policy
update failed and it's because the org
policy was put in place so that's good
if we can't add all users as a member
who can we add well most of the time
when you run a production service you
want to use service accounts so prior to
this demo I had created an object viewer
service account it doesn't actually have
object viewer permissions but I just
named an object viewer just for the sake
of simplicity so if I go back to storage
browser and I update the permissions
here I should be able to add that
service account to my bucket I'm going
to give it the same permission that I
tried before storage object viewer which
has read access to objects and I'm going
to select save and because this is
configured at the bucket level my
service account is going to have access
to all objects within this bucket as you
can see I haven't added any objects yet
so I'm going to go ahead and do that now
here I have
some folders that have some text files
in them let me drag and drop them here
on to the UI all three folders have
different prefixes but they all have the
same text files and then apples bananas
and cherries so how do we confirm that
our surface account actually has access
to all these objects
well easy way to do it is to use surface
account hmm
go to settings interoperability create a
key for your service account I already
have a key set up here but I don't
remember the secret for it so I'm just
gonna go ahead and make a new key if I
go over to terminal you can see that I
have this get object metadata with HTML
key script this script reads from
environment variables that I have to
export so I'm going to go ahead and do
that down exported the XS key and we'll
do the secret next great so now if I run
this script and I try to access my
buckets objects I should see that access
is granted and you can see that we have
successfully touched the metadata for
this object let me try some of the other
files
looks like access has been granted great
so if we go back to the browser I
mentioned earlier that I wanted to show
you an example of eye on conditions so
with eye on conditions you could set an
object prefix which would limit the
access to objects with a certain prefix
in the name so instead of granting
access to every object in the bucket
let's say I only wanted to grant access
to those with 20/20 in the name so to do
that go back to the bucket permissions
page I don't need to add the member
because the service account is already
on the bucket policy all I have to do is
edit it
so from here I can add a condition let
me call it 2023 fix and four condition
type will do resource name starts with
and we have to specify a resource name
format so the format is different for
each GCP service so this table right
here is really nice and you can see that
cloud storage objects follows this
format so I'm gonna grab that copy it in
here for object name it's not an object
name it's gonna be a prefix I'm gonna do
2020 slash and for [ __ ] name
I'm gonna put you see us next on air
with a bucket click Save now that I had
this set up I'm gonna check to make sure
that I have access only to 2020 and not
the other two
2018 should fail now
access denied 2019 should also fail
we'll try some other files also denied
but if we make it 20/20 access should be
granted great and that's how you set up
a object prefix and condition and with
that that concludes the demo thank you
very much thank you tester to conclude
as you have seen in this session GCSE
offers planet-scale object or blob
storage with a simple and unified API
and online latency characteristics and
it addresses a whole wide range of use
cases we see customers use this for
security is built into GCS by design and
default not as an afterthought and as
you saw from the various gia features
that just I just talked about we are
continuing to innovate and invest very
heavily in the security capabilities to
address your requirements and concerns
with GCS you can confidently store your
data at scale and trust us to keep your
data secure and safe with that I would
recommend if you haven't here tried some
of this GA features or if you haven't
tried some of these security best
practices that we just covered give it a
shot and let us know thank you